being your best self doesn't mean that
you have to accept what menopause throws
your way a Las Vegas doctor says she's
tried it all and relief is coming for
her patients in the form of a pellet a
news now anchor Kirsten Joyce visits the
dermabella medical spot to find out more
my body's responding positively a former
athlete in a very busy Health Care
executive Maureen Schaefer noticed her
energy levels changing when she turned
50. she consulted Dr Andrea Dempsey at
dermabella Medical Spa For answers she
said your hormone levels have really
sort of taken a hit with age which is
natural but we don't have to accept that
Maureen had many choices patches creams
pills there are different ways to put
hormones into your body but she chose
bioidentical hormone therapy delivered
in the shape of a pellet it's
individually dosed based on a person's
weight and lab results delivery systems
similar to how we make our own hormones
so it has its delivered to the body it's
more of a natural release the procedure
itself takes five minutes placing the
pellet Under the Skin with an incision
in the upper butt cheek the positive
effects last about four months Maureen
first tried this a year ago over the
course of gosh just two months I felt my
energy levels really rebounding my sleep
was coming back and just lots of other
things that started to make up positive
difference in my life would you say this
is the magic pill for anybody going
through menopause this palette makes
them feel younger and it's hard to
describe because we were like oh really
there's no such thing but the aches and
pains seem to improve sleep and it's a
gradual feeling and so it does feel like
kind of magic in the sense that it's
like it's not a dramatic difference but
it's sort of like I feel like myself
again Dr Dempsey would know she's a
patient herself she offered all the
other types of therapies for more than a
decade so you started your Med Spa in
2012 this location opened in 2019. yes
and in 2019 switched mostly to offering
just hormone pellet therapy she's done 2
000 procedures and wants women to know
you don't have to suffer through
menopause wanting to feel that
youthfulness again and knowing that it
doesn't mean we have to just get through
menopause like this is the rest of our
lives like why do we have to just you
know make it through Maureen has better
energy these days I have to say it's
been extraordinary for me prioritizing
these appointments as part of her normal
health care regimen keeping up with her
active lifestyle